democracy I believe in I mean I think  democracy is the psychedelic form of  government because I don't see it as a  product of rational thought I see it as  institutionalized and Archy it's  democracy is biology managed for human  purposes you know it honors the  biological unit it takes the biological  unit and gives it a vote and that's a  way for Mother Nature to then enter into  human history I mean I'm fairly mystical  about democracy sort of like William  Blake I think you know that we have to  deconstruct consciously deconstruct this  constipated classical industrial linear  dominator civilization that we're  trapped inside because it's a vehicle we  can't steer it's glued to the tracks  which run right over the cliff if we  cannot alter the assumptions of this  society if the George Bush's and Helmut  Kohl's of this world are going to  continue to run things then you know  head for the bunkers folks and pray  because the bunkers aren't going to be  any consolation